The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: So,
let's see, you probably
guessed on that quiz problem
three, it wasn't what I meant.
I get a zero for that problem.
But you'll get
probably good numbers,
so that's an election gift
if it comes out that way.
So they're all in the hands
of the TAs to be graded.
We have a holiday
Monday, I think.
We come back to Fourier.
Now, so we just have a
concentrated shot at Fourier,
just about eight or nine
lectures in November.
So stay with it and
that'll be of course
the subject of the third quiz.
Which will have no mistakes.
It'll be solved by the TAs in
advance and we'll spot things.
So, and if we have the quizzes
to return to you by Wednesday
that will be great.
I hope so, but they
have a big job.
A little bit, looking far
ahead, the end of Fourier,
the quiz is December 4th,
I think that's a Thursday.
And that's the
end of the course.
So December 4th.
So we'll be ending the
course a little bit early.
Because I'll be in Hong
Kong, to tell the truth.
And and we've done a lot,
and with the review sessions
we're really doing well.
So, that's the future, Fourier.
Today is an important day
too, finite elements in 2-D,
that's a major part of
computational science
and engineering.
The finite element idea, the
idea of using polynomials,
you can find in
some early papers
by Courant, a
mathematician in New York,
and by a guy in China,
neat guy named Feng Kang.
But those papers
were sort of, you
could do it this
way if you wanted.
It was really the structural
engineers in Berkeley
and elsewhere who made it
happen ten years later.
And the whole idea
has just blossomed.
Continues to grow.
So I had an early
book, in the '70s,
actually, about the mathematical
underpinnings, the math basis
for the finite element method.
And many other finite
element books have come.
Professor Bathe you know,
teaches a full of course
on that.
But, I think we can get the
idea of finite elements here.
We did them in 1-D, and now
there's a MATLAB problem
and I'd like to just describe
that particular problem
if I can, as an example.
And, of course, you
would use the code
that's printed in the book, and
that's available on the website
just to download.
But the problem is not
on a square domain.
It starts on a circle, so that
the first lines of the code,
calling the MATLAB command
squaregrid, are not applicable.
So you have to
create, then, a mesh.
Well, I have a suggested
mesh so I'll draw that,
and then from that
you want to make
a list of all the node points.
A list, P, of-- So what the
code needs is two lists.
Well, let me draw a picture
of, well, it's a circle.
And I'm going to be
solving Poisson's equation.
The equation will be
-u_xx-u_yy=4, in the circle.
So it's Poisson but with a
constant right-hand side.
That will mean that
all the integrals of f
times v, the right-hand side of
our discrete equation will be,
the integrals are all easy
because we just have a constant
there times the trial function.
OK, and then on the boundary
it's going to be u=0.
On the boundary.
So it's a classic problem.
And we can say what
the solution is.
So it's one with
a known solution.
I think it would be
x squared-- No, I
guess one, one minus x
squared minus y squared.
This should all be
on the .086 site.
I just didn't have a
chance to look this morning
to be sure it got up.
So you can watch, here.
So that, I hope, does
solve the problem.
Two x derivatives give us a two,
two y derivatives another two,
so we get four.
So we know the answer;
the question is,
and I'm interested in this
question, for research reasons
too, is what's the error
when you go to a polygon?
You go to a-- These
curved boundaries
don't get correctly saved.
You approximate them
by straight lines.
That would be the first idea.
And with this,
all this symmetry,
let's keep the problem nice
and use a regular polygon.
So maybe I'll try to draw
one with about eight sides,
but-- OK.
So we impose u=0 at these nodes.
So u is zero at those nodes,
and then we have a mesh.
So we want to create a mesh.
OK, so with all
the symmetry here,
the natural idea would be to
start with eight pieces, or M
pieces if I have, this
is a regular M side,
let's say, and I'll take M
to be eight in this picture.
And I think we can work
on just one triangle.
By rotational symmetry,
all those triangles
are going to be the same.
So I think our domain is
really this one triangle here.
That's where we're working.
And in that triangle, I think we
have zero boundary conditions.
And across this edge I think
we have natural boundary
conditions.
Slope zero, if I see
the picture correctly.
The rotational
symmetry would mean
that things are not changing.
That every triangle is the same.
So I think on these boundaries
it's the Neumann condition,
dU/dn=0.
And I'm frankly not sure
what to do at the origin,
so I'll maybe just
try both ways and see.
OK, so there is a real problem.
Of course, it's
artificial in the sense
that we know the answer.
But it's a real open question of
what does the error look like,
from doing that.
So that's the goal
and let me just
say the problem
I'll ask you to do,
and it probably is quite enough
to be ready for next Friday,
is to use piecewise
linear elements.
Which is what I'm going to do.
What every discussion of finite
elements will begin with,
linear elements.
Those pyramids that I spoke
about at the end of last time.
So that's what I
hope, but actually I
would be highly interested, if
anybody got into the problem,
to try quadratic elements.
So I'll just say here,
second-degree quadratic
polynomials would
be more accurate.
Would be more accurate.
So, in other words,
this is a first type
of finite element called P_1,
for polynomials of degree one.
These guys, I would call P_2,
for polynomials of degree two.
And I've mentioned here the
possibility of using quads.
Instead of triangles, if
I had squares for example,
the simplest element
would be a Q_1.
So these are-- If I
manage today to tell you
about how to use P_1 and P_2
and Q_1, you're on your way.
And for the requirements
of this course,
P_1 is the first
point to understand.
OK.
While I'm speaking
about codes and meshes,
let me draw the mesh I proposed
in the homework problem.
So I thought OK, we just have
to have a simple mesh here.
So let me draw that line in.
I know all these points, right?
This is (0, 0) here.
And that point's on the circle.
And so is this, that point might
be, so what's the angle there?
That angle is probably pi/8.
The whole angle would be
2pi/8, and eight of them
would go all the way around.
So I think that angle is pi/8.
And so this point would
be (cos(pi/8), sin(pi/8)).
We know where they are.
But that's going to be
what we have to list.
We have to list where are the
coordinates of all the mesh
points.
So let me describe the
rest of the mesh points
and then see what that
list would look like.
And once you've created the
list, the code will take over.
And then you plot the results
and see what's going on.
So let me suggest a mesh.
It's pretty straightforward.
I just divided this piece
into N, this center thing
into N-- So I called
that distance h.
So Nh gets me out to here.
Whatever that is, that's
cos(pi/8), I guess,
that's the x coordinate
of that line.
So those are mesh points and
then let me keep drawing these.
So these will be
mesh points too,
and these will be
mesh points too.
So at this point, I've got
probably 12 or 13 mesh points.
But I've got quads, right?
Well, I've got a
couple of triangles
here that I'm not going
to touch, those are fine.
But these are quads
and they could
be used with the Q_1
element, but I'm thinking
let's stay with triangles.
So I just suggested
to put in triangles,
put in these diagonals,
keeping symmetry.
And so there's the mesh.
There's the mesh.
And then what does
the code ask for?
So I've got 13 mesh points.
And the code, first
of all it wants
a list of the coordinates
of all those mesh points.
So that the code will-- And I
better number them, of course.
So let me number them
one, shall I number
them the center guys first,
one, two, three, four, five,
and then up here six,
seven, eight, nine, now
I don't know if this
is a good numbering.
10, 11, 12, 13.
Why don't we, just to have
some consistency within plans,
why don't you, you
don't have to take N=4.
I hope you'll take, what did
I take N as four or five?
Yeah, right.
N is 4.
But you'll want to
try different N's.
N=4 would be a good crude
start to see what's going
on, but then I hope you'll go
higher and get better accuracy.
And you can see how the accuracy
improves, how you get closer
to that, as N gets bigger.
OK, we've got the
nodes numbered.
Oh, I better number
the triangles.
OK, how shall we
number the triangles?
Shall we do along
the top, or this?
I don't know.
What do you want to do for the
numbering of the triangles?
Maybe run along
the top, and then
run along the bottom,
because then it'll
practically be a copy.
So I didn't leave myself much
space, but one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven.
Seven triangles along the top
and seven along the bottom,
so I have 14 triangles
in this mesh.
So it's a mesh with 14
triangles and 13 nodes.
And I know the positions
of everyone, right?
I know the x,y
coordinates of every one.
So what the code will want is
a list of those coordinates.
So a list p, p will be
a list of coordinates.
The first guy will be-- Of the
nodes so 13 rows, 3 columns.
So it's a little 13 by
3 matrix that tells you
where all the nodes are.
So the first one on that
list would be (0,0).
That's for node one.
And the second one would
be whatever the coordinates
of that are, something,
zero. (h,0), I guess it is.
The third one will be (2h,0),
and so on, and then complete
the list of 13 positions.
So you have then told the
code where all the nodes are.
What else do you
have to tell it?
Not much.
You now have to tell
it about the triangles.
So now for every, why
do I say three columns?
Maybe only two, is it?
You see the point already.
I've forgotten, maybe, yeah.
I don't see why.
Well for triangles, I'm
going to need three,
for nodes maybe
it's only got two.
Maybe it's 13 by 2.
I don't see why I need three.
But, anyway.
Then the other
list is triangles.
So this will be the
list t, and so it
takes triangle number one.
Which is right here.
That very first triangle.
And what does it have to
tell us about triangle one?
The three nodes.
If it tells us the
three node numbers,
and this list, p, gave their
positions, we've got it.
So how many triangles
did that I have?
14?
So t will be 14 by 3,
and so the first guy
will be just one, node
number one, node number two,
and node number six.
That will tell us which
is the first triangle.
And the second triangle, I
guess I've drawn from two
to seven to six, right?
That's a very skinny
triangle up there
but it's the one that started
at node two, went up to seven
and back to six.
So a list like that.
And then the code
will do the rest.
I hope.
Almost all the rest.
The code will create the matrix
K. It'll create the matrix
K with, it'll be singular.
Boundary conditions
won't yet be in there.
And then a final
step after that, K,
or maybe we could call
it K_0, is created,
a final step will be to fix u.
At least at these three points.
So these three will
be boundary nodes.
And as I say, I'm not too sure
about that one, I apologize.
At those boundary
nodes I'm going
to take the values to be zero.
So this is going to be
zero along the whole edge,
because if it's zero there,
zero there, zero there and zero
there, and if it's
linear, it's zero.
So the final sort of
subroutine in the code,
the final group of commands you
want to impose, zeroes here,
that should then make
the matrix K invertible,
and then you've
got KU=F to solve.
So what the code is doing
is creating K and F.
You see the overall picture?
I jumped right into
this particular mesh,
particular problem, but
now I really should back up
to where it starts.
This is going to be the weak
form of Laplace, Poisson,
maybe I'll make a little space
to put in Poisson's name too.
You have a picture already of
what this weak form is about,
so now I'm really
backing up to the start.
I take the equation and
I get its weak form.
And remember that's in
the continuous case,
as it was in the quiz problem.
The first step is the
continuous weak form,
and then the second
step is choose
test functions and trial-- I'm
sorry, gosh, I'm in bad shape
here.
Because they're the same.
This isn't my
worst error, today.
But those are trial functions,
and these are test functions.
OK, questions at this point,
because I've-- Yeah, thank you.
Good.
Let's look at this picture.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Because-- We did.
That's right.
So because my
question is what is--
The continuous problem I
would like to solve has u=0
on the polygon.
So in a way you can
forget the circle,
where we know the answer.
Now, we really are
looking on the polygon,
and I would like to
know what's the solution
like on that polygon.
And then so there are
two steps, the first step
was start with a circle,
we have the answer.
Second step is go to a polygon,
continuous problem, Poisson's
equation in the polygon.
How different is that from this?
Because this will not
satisfy the polygon
boundary conditions.
So that's the circle answer.
Then the question is,
what's the polygon answer.
And I don't know that.
You may say a regular
polygon, you can't do that.
I didn't think you can.
It's amazing, but probably
a triangle or a square.
So if M is three or four,
probably some formulas
would be available.
But I think once
we get higher, I
don't know the answer to
the Dirichlet problem,
to Poisson's equation on a
polygon, on a regular polygon.
And that's what I would really
like to know more about.
And how do I find
out more about it?
By finite elements.
With your help.
Taking that polygon,
breaking it into a mesh,
looking only at one triangle
just for simplicity,
and getting u finite elements.
Well, I should say u_(P_1).
That's the finite element
solution using linear.
I would really like
to know u_(P_2),
the finite element solution
which will be better,
if I use quadratics.
So now I get the
fun of describing
the linear elements, the
quadratic elements, the quads.
But did I answer
that question OK?
Yeah.
So this is the problem I would
like to know the answer to.
If I have this
equation, zero boundary
conditions on a regular
polygon with M sides,
what's the answer?
And it's going to be close to
this, but it won't be the same.
Because this does not
vanish on the polygon edges.
And I would like to
compare the slopes, too.
So the homework problem
asked you not only to compare
u_circle with u_(P_1),
but also the slopes.
The slopes here are
easy, slopes here
are easy because it's a
bunch of flat functions.
So the slopes are just
constant in each triangle.
OK, I'm guessing that the error
gets smaller as you go in.
I think that if
you plot the error,
it'll be largest out
here and get small there.
But remains to be seen.
So I hope you
enjoy-- yeah, good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
Rather than seven.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG:
No, the middle.
There's nothing magic
about any particular mesh.
I just chose this
mesh as pretty good,
and actually, I'm imagining
M could get pretty big.
That would be interesting.
M=8 would be interesting,
M=16, M=1,024,
now then I'd really
get interested.
OK, but so if M is 1,024, then
this side would be very small.
Right?
And I just wanted
more triangles.
Actually, I would like
more than I've got.
I'd like, if M was
really big, then
probably N should be
at least that big.
So I should have a
thousand this way,
if this is just a tiny bit.
I just want little
tiny h, and then, yeah.
Actually, that might
not be too bad.
If M and N were
roughly comparable,
then that length
would be roughly
comparable to these lengths.
And the triangles would
be pretty good shapes.
And that's what
you're looking for.
I think there's a lot of
experiments to be done here.
So, I'm thinking
then of M and N. Here
I took N to be just four.
When M was eight.
That's fine.
But if you keep M and N
roughly the same size,
then you've got triangles that
are not too long and skinny.
I'll tell you when
you might want.
So generally you want
nice shaped triangles.
You don't want angles very
small or very large, usually.
But there would be,
anybody in Course 16
can imagine that if I
am computing the flow
field past a wing, that long,
thin triangles in the direction
of the wing are natural.
I mean, somehow a problem
like true aerodynamics
is by no means isotropic.
I mean, the
direction of the wing
is kind of critical to whether
the plane flies, right?
So don't make the wing vertical.
And if you want
accuracy, then you
have long, thin triangles in
the direction of the flow.
But here we're not
doing a flow problem.
We haven't got shocks,
or trailing edges,
and other horrible stuff
that makes planes fly.
We just got Poisson's equation.
OK.
Thanks for those good
questions, another one.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR STRANG: What would
the dimension look like?
Ah, would you like me to show
you something about quadratics?
Yeah.
Shall I jump into
quadratics, it's kind of fun.
Quadratics, so let
me just do-- So I'll
come back to the weak
form, right it's totally--
Oh, I'll do it now.
It's so simple I don't
want to forget it.
The weak form, so I write the
equation down, -u_xx-u_yy=f.
This is the continuous weak
form, equal f(x,y), OK?
So that's the strong form.
And I've made it the Laplacian
here to keep it simple,
and any right-hand side.
OK, how do I get
to the weak form?
Just remind me, I multiply
both sides by any test function
v(x,y).
Multiply by v(x,y),
and then what do I do?
I integrate over
the whole region.
So that's the weak form, dxdy,
this is for all v, all v(x,y),
all, I'll say all
admissible v(x,y).
So that's the weak form.
If this holds for this great
family of v's, the idea behind
it is, that if this holds for
all these trial functions,
test functions, v(x,y), the only
way that can happen is for this
to actually equal that.
That's a fundamental lemma
in this part of math,
and of course it has
to be spelled out
more than I'm doing in words.
But the idea is that if these
hold for such a large class
of v(x,y), then the only
way that can happen is
for the strong form to hold.
For this to actually match this.
OK, so that's the start.
But then what's the next
step in the weak form?
I like the right-hand
side but I'm not
so crazy about the
left-hand side.
I'm not crazy about
it because this
has second derivatives of u,
and my little roof functions,
pyramid functions, haven't
got second derivatives.
So I would be dead in
the water without doing
the natural step that makes
everything beautiful, which is?
Integration by parts.
Integrate by parts.
Move derivatives off of u,
onto v. One derivative onto v,
off of u, so then u and v
each have one derivative.
I can use my piecewise
linear, piecewise quadratic,
all my finite elements
are going to go fine.
So I integrate by parts.
So integrate by parts, and
what is that mean in 2-D?
Of course I have a
double integral here.
So integrate by parts, that mean
you use the Green's formula.
That was the key point of this
Green, or Gauss-Green formula.
Can I do it first in, this is
-div(grad u), times v dxdy,
we can write out all the terms.
We can use vector notation.
I could use that nabla, that
upside down triangle notation,
or whatever.
But maybe good to see
it a few different ways.
So what's the point?
When I integrate by parts, that
minus disappears to a plus,
I have a double integral then,
and these derivatives move
off of-- I'm taking one
derivative off of here,
the divergence moves over there,
but when the divergence moves
onto v it becomes?
The transpose.
It becomes gradient.
And so this is gradient
of u, gradient of v, dxdy.
Plus boundary terms.
The integral of,
what is, let's see.
What do I have in this integral,
I have grad u dot n, times v
around the boundary.
And with my boundary conditions
that's going to be gone,
so I can come back to that.
Now, you all looked
a little uncertain
when I wrote Green's
formula this way.
For this problem I can
write it more easily.
This is my left side.
I want to write
the answer, I just
want to write this weak
form in a much simpler form.
So let me say, what
have I got here.
Well, all I've got
is one derivative
is moving off of u and
onto v. And the minus sign
is disappearing, so I
have du/dx times dv/dx.
Right?
One off of u, onto
v. The other term,
one y derivative, moving off
of this and onto v. Minus sign
again going to a plus.
du/dy, dv/dy.
That's the integral.
That's it, that's cool.
Easy to do.
And on the right-hand side
of course I have no change.
The integral of
f(x,y) v(x,y) dy.
Now, that's the weak form.
dxdy.
Here it is, weak form.
That's pretty nice.
Beautifully symmetric,
so the matrix
that comes up when we plug in
finite specific trial functions
and test functions is going
to be a symmetric matrix
K. And the integrals are
of first derivatives,
so as long as our functions,
our trial functions and test
functions are continuous,
that is, they shouldn't jump.
If the trial functions
or test functions jump,
then if I have a jump, then the
derivative would be a delta.
I'd have another
delta here, I'd have
an integral delta, a delta times
delta, and I don't want that.
That's infinite.
Those discontinuous elements
would not be conforming,
and that's a whole new world
of discontinuous Galerkin.
I'd have to impose
penalty stuff,
and Professor
Peraire I mentioned,
and others, Professor Darmofal
in aero, are experts on this.
We're doing continuous Galerkin.
CG.
Our piecewise linear,
piecewise quadratic,
they'll be continuous.
All I have to do is
these derivatives.
Integrate those things and
that's what the code will do.
OK, I've got to the weak form.
That's the weak form.
Now comes the
finite element idea.
So there is our weak form, now
ready for the finite element
idea.
OK, so what was that idea?
That's the continuous problem.
Now, the finite element idea
is, plug in U as a combination--
Let me write out the terms.
You know what's coming here.
If I'm using finite
elements, I'm
going to choose nice
polynomials phi, say N of them.
That would be like,
one for every node,
so I would have
13 functions here.
I'm going to choose the V's
to be the same as the phis.
And then, I'm working
then in 13 dimensions
instead of infinite dimensions.
So what do I do?
For this limited subspace,
this finite element subspace,
this piecewise polynomial,
piecewise linear subspace,
I plug that into the
weak form and I test it
against 13 V's, which are phis.
So I plug that in,
so now what is K?
Now let me just say, so I
now have the integral of,
yeah I guess I'd
better plug it in.
K_ij would then
be the integral --
I'm just copying the weak form
in -- Of dU/dx d-- no, sorry,
I'd better just
plug it in first.
dU/dx*dV/dx plus dU/dy*dV/dy,
those are the integrals I have
to do.
And on the right
hand side I have
to do the f-integral. fV dxdy.
OK, plug that in.
That's the integral
over the whole domain.
When I plug it in this U is a
combination of known functions
and the V's will
be the same guys.
So what am I going to get here?
It's just as in 1-D. So no
new ideas entering here.
The new idea's going to enter
when I construct these phis.
Let me just say,
though, one thing.
In 1-D, we pretty
much had a choice
of-- When it was one dimension.
Just remember that.
In one dimension, when I
had these hat functions,
when I had these guys,
integrated against these guys,
I pretty much had
a choice of did
I want to think about
integrating that hat
function against that one.
Or actually it was
their derivatives.
It was the integral of U, yeah.
Of phi, what I needed
was all the integrals
of phi_i', phi_j'.
Those are what I needed, these
go into K. Into the matrix K.
In fact, that's
what equals K_ij,
the integral of phi prime.
In 1-D. OK.
Now, what I was going
to say, I could do it
this way if I wanted.
But you remember the
other way to do it?
Was element at a time.
So this was one method here.
That found the entries of
K separately, one by one.
The other way was take
the elements, one by one.
So the other way was take an
element like this element.
It's got two functions,
two trial functions
are involved there.
There's a little two by
two, so this is four.
Two by two element matrices K_e.
And the quiz recalled that part.
That approach.
So what I want to say
is that's the right way
to do it in two dimensions.
A triangle at a time.
That's the way the
code will do it.
It creates these little
element matrices,
and then it stamps them into
the big matrix K. Alright.
So I want to do this integral
one triangle at a time.
Is the good way.
OK, and that's what
the code will do.
Actually, I think
that the best way
to learn these steps is just
to read the lines of the code.
You can read them in the
book, page 303 or something.
And you'll see it just doing all
the steps that need to be done.
One triangle at a time.
So, now.
Now comes the fun.
I get to answer, what do these
piecewise linear elements look
like?
What do the quadratic
elements look like?
What do the Q_1, quad
This was the golden
age of finite elements,
when people invented
these ways to create
piecewise polynomials.
And it continues.
People are still inventing,
I had a email this week,
somebody says I've
got spectral elements.
People are going higher
and higher degrees.
You, know sixth
degree, eighth degree.
In order to get more accuracy.
OK, let's start with P_1.
How do I describe a P_1
element inside a triangle?
So in a triangle,
the unknowns will
be the value-- This
has a height U_1,
this has a height U_2, and
a height U_3 at those nodes.
Inside the triangle, the
function U is linear.
a+bx+cy.
Then, you see that if I know
these three values, then
I know these three numbers.
And vice versa.
There's a three by
three matrix, right?
There has to be a three by--
Any time you see pictures
like this, like the
good part of 18.085
is to realize that if I
have three numbers here,
three values and I've
got three coefficients,
that there's some three by
three matrix that connects them
that you're going to need.
That's like a meta-message
of this course.
Is, you've got to translate
between the node values
and the coefficients.
Because the node values
are the unknowns, right?
These are the guys that
are multiplying the pyramid
function, this is multiplying
a pyramid function
with height one at that
point, going down to zero.
So this one will be a pyramid
function of height U_2
times one, going down to zero.
And U_3.
So we've got a flat
function in here.
And it looks exactly like that.
OK?
So what do I want to say?
We know the positions of these
three nodes from our list p,
right?
These were the crucial
things we needed.
The positions of all the
nodes, we know where they are.
Then there has to be a three
by three matrix that will now
connect to the coefficients.
Why do we want the coefficients?
Because those are what
we do when we integrate.
The coefficients
are what we need,
we need to integrate
dU/dx, dU/dy, dU/dz.
Sorry, dU/dx, dU/dy.
Are you visualizing this overall
solution capital U, yeah.
So the overall
solution capital U,
you should visualize
with a combination of all
the little U's, is
zero here and then
it's going to go up in these
triangles and bend around
and, I don't know,
maybe down again.
Or maybe, no, maybe
it keeps going up.
This is probably
the largest value,
because it's the largest
value in the correct solution.
So is this is probably going to
be the highest point of this,
what's-- The
Forbidden City, right?
In China, in Beijing is like,
or a single-- Do pagodas
have flat--?
No.
We we will meet
pagoda functions.
But this would be just an
ordinary western roof, I guess.
Just flat pieces.
Yeah.
OK, see, you've got
to see the whole thing
and then you look at each piece.
Each piece looks like that,
and the integrals are doable.
OK, so while I'm going here,
I want to do quadratics.
You'll get the idea right away.
So, same triangle, now I'm
going to have quadratics.
So I'm now going to have,
so this won't be the arrow,
this arrow will now go this way.
I'm going to have d x
squared, exy, and f y squared.
So now how many
coefficients have
I got to determine a quadratic?
Six, right? a, b, c, d, e, f.
How many nodes do I need?
Six.
Where are they?
Well, the natural positions are
those guys in the mid-points.
So now, those are all nodes now.
Some nodes are at
vertices of triangles,
some nodes are at midpoints.
But remember, we've
got other triangles
hooking on here,
many other triangles,
all with their own six nodes.
Well, not their own,
because they share.
That's a big point.
So there's a grid of triangles,
with nodes for quadratic.
And we've got one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten, 11, 12, 13,
14, 15, 16 nodes, I think.
And within each triangle,
this is what we've got.
So there's a six by six
matrix for each triangle.
A six by six matrix
which will connect
the values U_1, U_2, U_3, U_4,
U_5, U_6 for this triangle.
Connect those six heights
with these six numbers.
And what will the roof look
like within that triangle?
Well, sort of curved.
A parabola, right?
A parabola somehow in 2-D,
it'll look like this, yeah.
Yeah.
And here's the key question.
Will that roof, that curvy
roof, fit the one over there?
Because if it didn't
fit, we're in trouble.
This derivative would
have a delta function,
and we've got delta functions,
and integrals squaring them
would give infinite.
So here's the question.
Why does this roof, using these
six points, fit onto the roof
that uses U_7, U_8, U_9,
and U_3, U_4 and U_5?
Why do those two
roofs fit together?
This is the fun of
piecewise polynomials?
Of course, the
slope will change.
But the roof won't have a gap.
Water won't go through it.
Why's that?
Do you see why?
Because what do they share, what
do those two curvy roofs share?
They share a side.
They share the same
values along the side.
And are those three
values that are
shared along the side
sufficient to make
it match all along the side?
Yes.
That's the important question.
Finite elements lives or
dies on that question.
The answer is yes, because
along that side, if I just
focus on that side,
where these three
values are shared on both sides,
by the triangle on both sides.
Along that edge, what kind
of a function have I got?
It's second degree.
This is whatever, when I
restrict this to just run along
a line, it's a parabola.
And the parabola is determined
by those three values.
So having it right
at three points
means I have it
right the whole way.
Yeah.
So there you see what quadratic
elements would look like,
and you could extend
the code in the book
and on the CSE site to work
for quadratic elements.
And you want to just guess what
cubic elements could look like?
I'm sorry, we've run
five minutes over,
but maybe finite
elements is worth it.
So if I had cubic elements,
any idea how many?
So I'm now going up to,
I'm adding g x cubed,
h, i, j, any idea how many
coefficients I now have?
Four new ones plus
these six is ten.
I need ten nodes.
Where I am I going to put
ten nodes in this triangle?
I want to put them, I'd like
to have some on the edges.
Because the edges help me make
triangles match each other.
They'll just be
like bowling balls.
So here's six, oops, that
wouldn't be believable.
Is that right?
Four, three, two, and one.
Yeah.
OK.
So, now I've got a
bubble node inside
and I've got four nodes of
vertices and two points,
at two 1/3 points,
and that will then
match the triangle next to it.
Because four points
determine a cubic.
There you go, I
hope you have fun,
I hope you have a great holiday.
I'll see you
Wednesday for Fourier
and always open for
questions on the MATLAB.